here now with reaction here's the house
oversight committee chair James Comer is
with us you know we're really looking at
two things here Congressman one is what
your committee is looking into the Biden
family and this foreign criminal money
making scheme what do you make of what
we know right now in other words you you
actually told Ted Cruz on his podcast
that Joe Biden has been selling access
to our enemies for decades will that
thou be proven
well I think we're getting closer every
day we're at the point now we're in the
deposition phase we need people like
Devin Archer to come forward and tell us
what they know we already have bank
records we have emails we have text
messages we have phone records we have
testimony from other people so we know a
lot about what Joe Biden's involvement
was we're at the point to where we need
people to come in under oath and go into
more detail because I think all roads
point to Joe Biden I think any
reasonable American would see that but
for this mainstream media Sean we have
to have a whole lot more evidence than
Adam Schiffer Jamie Raskin did when they
were going after Trump but we're going
to provide the evidence and I think
we're making progress every day
now we know that Devin Archer had
canceled a couple of times on you I we
expect that he will testify before your
committee a week from today uh you had
also previously said that you expect
Hunter to face between six and ten
criminal referrals uh now Joe Biden told
the American people again and again and
again that he never ever talked to his
son or his brother or anybody for that
matter about his farm about their Farm
business dealings China Russia
Kazakhstan Ukraine Romania Mexico and
about a dozen other countries correct me
if I'm wrong but now Miranda Devine is
reporting that Devin Archer we expect
that he will talk about very specific
examples where Joe Biden was was put on
a speaker phone by Hunter in front of
his farm business partners was was he
the closer of these deals
it sure sounds a lot like that Sean you
you look at the laptop and all the
people that Joe Biden claimed he never
had any dealings with or didn't know
there are pictures there are text
messages there are emails uh there's
evidence through and through that shows
Joe Biden knew these people he spent
time with these people and he
communicated with these people now we
know of several instances where Joe
Biden was in fact in direct
communication with some of these
business associates I guess you could
call them I call them people who are
foreign Nationals sending money through
shell companies to the Biden family but
at any rate Joe Biden was a lot more
involved in Hunter Shady business
schemes than he has ever admitted how
many specific examples again Joe Biden
said he never even talked to his son
about this how many specific examples
how many pictures how much direct
evidence do you have that Joe Biden lied
to the American people and in fact his
family benefited financially and how
many millions are we talking about
well we've got already proven over 10
million dollars and we're sitting on a
lot more bank records we're going to
bring people in now to try to explain
where this money came from because as as
we've said before on the show Sean many
of these shell companies he had people
like Rob walker uh like Devin Archer
whose name was also involved in some of
these companies that received the
initial money wires from the foreign
Nationals and then they were then
transferred into the Biden shell
companies and then laundered down to the
Biden family this is a very organized
complex scheme that has taken a long
time to figure out it was difficult by
Design that's what the form 1023 said
that's what the CEO barisma said that
investigators would take 10 years to
unravel this because they sent the money
through sent the bribes through so many
different bank accounts but I think
we're getting there we just need people
to come in now like the IRS
whistleblowers did in front of the
American people last week and tell the
truth
all right chairman Comer thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else